so this happened at a rock concert
or something like that
why is your face looking out there like
that
what's wrong what happened
whoa what happened
oh speechless okay okay let's just all
right
oh no i know
i know it
yeah
[Laughter]
okay hold on
guys if you like this video subscribe
because this [ __ ]
is demonetized
[Music]
i think i heard a shot
i think i heard
[Music]
[Applause]
somebody get you the [ __ ] out of here
okay
if you guys can't see what's going on
you guys can go google it if you really
need to see it if you just want me to
describe it so essentially who is this
this is like some kind of cover band
yeah you know she's afraid to get the
message machine yeah they do other stuff
and this was one of their songs and uh
the artist in question uh i can't
remember her name like sophia something
she um brought somebody on stage
essentially peed in the dude's mouth
and
made it part of the set
[Music]
all right
listen it's a performance
now in this day and age
i see that
not my cup of tea
but it's two consenting adults probably
getting a panic attack right now just a
minute i see you scratching i know
exactly
like it's
giving me anxiety right now just
thinking about it it's two consenting
adults it's crazy he lived his king and
that was that
now um there's not much insight to give
to this i know this in the contemporary
world
right here in montreal there was another
artist
by the name of matthias
that decided to as a performance dance
performance it's contemporary dance
that is a performance she would pee in a
pot she won a prize for that so
i think it's [ __ ] up
some of y'all have the weirdest boners
right now
but at the end of the day it's too
consenting at all there's nothing much
to say move on it's [ __ ] up
not something i necessarily want to see
that was a lot of pee there was not a
tinkle that was not a tinkle that was a
sprinkler that was a splint
that was a lot
sprinkler sprinkler little star and you
know what in her defense i will say she
did that [ __ ] on b
i was paying attention i realized the
breakdown ended right as she stopped
peeing
to be able to synchronize your urination
with
the flow of the song as the flow of your
that's impressive that's all right
that's a lot of flow and and
i got she didn't pee on her legs
because most girls when you squat i mean
that [ __ ] is all over the place i'm
open-minded
no you're not i'm open-minded i'm not
that open-minded exactly okay cool yeah
kick cool cool
you know what i'm saying like
i don't care about topless beaches nude
beaches like whatever there's a place
for everything yeah
depending on people in public am i too
old did i tell you about the time i was
where does this world tune you
did i tell you about the time i was
about am i too old if you you're getting
told it's been a door it's been a couple
of times that about you speaking like
you're you're a bad guy i also confess
coven happened
am i too old
or is the world to you
because
if you said nine [ __ ] you're too old
coleman's covered like [ __ ] that's
that's a lot of you and you but i have
the feeling that's not the first time
that happened in the show what
peeing on someone's face i'm pretty sure
it happened it's not the first time i'm
pretty sure
i can imagine that at a sex show
if i go to watch your cover band
yeah it's like i'm the scat man
literally excuse me
literally and
[Music]
i really don't think i'm too old i think
this is just too new no i think it
happened it's just [ __ ] up man covered
[ __ ] a whole bunch of people
covered [ __ ] so much people up and
they'd be an inside that they're like
hey once i get out these doors
i'm hugging everybody yeah well once i'm
getting out of these doors i'm getting
pissed on
they said yo forget social discipline
you'll get close to me and my pee
that's a lot that's a lot that's a lot
guys and
listen i'm all for artists doing what
they want to do but some of it just
looks like degeneracy which is what you
know
some of it just uses like the the label
of art as an umbrella so they can just
go and do weird stuff and the band has
since apologized they said this doesn't
represent who they are
i don't know it seems very orchestrated
to be honest with you but
on the off chance that it's not it's
like to me it just looks like degeneracy
no
okay so what you rather like what you
rather like
people pissing on people's head
or people dying at a concert my question
is to what degree can someone get pissed
on what you mean to what that goes
against one listen
i don't know what degree it is all i
know is
[Laughter]
to what degree does one get peed on the
only thing i know is that i don't know
when i saw that i couldn't believe what
i was looking at
it's very like difficult to shock me
shocked did i tell you about the time i
was a bouncer and i had to open up a
door at a rate yeah and it was someone
eating their feces
that's the whole story really
i had to call back up because
well i didn't know it was if it was
their feces i know they were that girl
was eating feces now i don't know the
story doesn't say if the feces was
already there when she got there and she
took a whiff of that [ __ ] and she was
like mmm chilly
and she went in
y'all may talk or she sat down squatted
and she remembered the chili that she
had and she's like nah that [ __ ] was
really too good and she ate it the story
doesn't say that but um yeah let's call
it what it is degeneracy yeah let's call
it what it is definitely call it what it
is some people want to [ __ ] on stage and
call it art no just say you want a
[ __ ] public
say you got a thing people want to be
able to take doo-doos in a park and be
like this is not public dedication it's
this art piece of [ __ ] i don't know just
some something y'all just degenerates
and that's what i thought yeah you have
to you have to walk back in the crowd
and stay in the crowd and enjoy the rest
of the show that's what [ __ ] me it's
like you got to stand next to the
[ __ ] that got peed on no now you
you smell like pee yeah you know how you
got and the guy got up and he started
spitting that [ __ ] out like he's
goldberg no no no you're you're not one
we're not goldberg to we're not part of
this show you wanted to get peed on i'm
not part of that don't fling that thing
up in the air uh sometimes screaming hey
oh you know last week here's some people
that's stupid
last week
last week i really thought how terrible
would it be to die at a travis scott
concert just hearing blown out base just
imagine dying
and the last thing you see is a girl
peeing on a dude on stage i don't want
to pass out what the [ __ ] is that and
it's just that's a left thing you see
some people got more need help some
people got the privilege of having their
their life flashing and some other
people got people flashing yeah in front
of them before they died that's crazy
you know no i wouldn't yeah no i mean
that's just
yeah it's just yeah degeneres
this is one of the times where if a
stampede did happen i would say 100 of
the blame is on the artist
i'm not gonna friendship i don't care
who the artist is
if i see them peeing on somebody i'm out
and also how do you select for somebody
to get peed on
do you say beforehand
drip drip trip i'm gonna pee on you you
say that or how do you get someone how
did she know it's not even that what
it's just imagine imagine i'm a [ __ ]
tech guy
i'm a tech guy at a console and she's
like
i'm gonna have to pick that up
i'm burning the whole goddamn
huh
i can see that i can't you're just this
one's giving me anxiety
i'm out of this bike it's your kids
i'm burning the whole goddamn there's
not no you're not not picking up
european then you're you're you're the
staged the pedrants change that that
just makes no sense and after that
you're gonna apologize like that's not
who we represent it is now
what was the name of the band
my man is out he's out anyways yeah
that's it for the video tell us what you
think
brass against
well
guess what
either you change your name or
who's a singer
check it out
such an emotional performance rumor has
it there wasn't a dry eye in the house
else wrote even dogs don't pee on each
other
that's crazy
it's true
some of y'all have the weirdest boners
right now i know
that's just crazy though